und weiter geht es mit diesen heftigen
bildern aus neapel
dort haben die menschen in der nacht
gegen eine ausgangssperre und einen
geplanten lockdown protestiert die
demonstranten haben feuerwerkskörper
geworfen und rauchbomben gezündet die
polizei setzte unter anderem tränengas
ein um die lage zu kontrollieren
zuvor hatte der regionalpräsident
vincenzo di luca pläne für einen lock
down angekündigt denn auch in italien
steigen die korona zahlen extrem am
freitag wurden über 19.000
neuinfektionen gemeldet mehr als 1000
menschen werden derzeit
intensivmedizinisch behandelt
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren